[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
it's a comedy podcast about death we
answer your questions we provide you
with dubious advice and we bring you all
the week's news from both Mars which is
a cold dead rock in the vacuum of space
and AFC Wimbledon which is the greatest
fan owned institution in the world I am
here today with the lovely Karen
Halligan Karen tell us a little bit
about yourself well I am an artist
illustrator and part-time Jedi mostly
the part-time is because I have kids so
I'll get back to my studies for Jedi
training at a future date I'm from
Boston and I do a lot of pop culture
mashups Star Wars Disney Doctor Who and
then I was lucky enough to work on Hanks
wizard school last year and I did all
the art for that which was an incredible
experience
you can find Karen at her Etsy store she
also has stuff at dftba.com your
friendly neighborhood tailor and also I
should add that the game that she did
the illustrations for wizard school will
be available soon for the Christmas
holidays so usually the beginning of the
podcast Karen we talked about ha just
how we're doing how are you I'm pretty
good yeah I mean I'm a little anxious
just because of the usually I'm in my
basement when I do this
but other than that I'm well that's a
few people here that's weird
usually you're just comments yeah it's
weird to me that you have bodies
it's amazed somebody just got the first
comment congratulations
that reminds me of my all-time favorite
Hank joke what did the YouTube commenter
say when they finished fifth in the
marathon first alright we're going to
skip the short poem for the day because
I didn't prepare one if you come to my
thing later today I'll be reading a
little bit of a short poem so maybe
that'll be that'll be better
but yeah so we're gonna start with a
question Karen this question comes from
Fiona and she writes dear Dear John and
Hank this summer Apple ran a promotion
if you brought okay so when we make the
podcast I make a lot of mistakes and
then I just say Nick back up and that
means Nick the editor the podcast should
back up and we're gonna start over so
Nick back up this summer Apple ran a
promotion where if you bought a laptop
you got a free pair of $300 Wireless
Beats headphones I needed a laptop for
college so I got a free pair of Beats
since I spend so much time walking
around campus in New York City wireless
headphones are super convenient to
listen to the pod and other stuff while
I walk however every time I wear them I
feel totally obnoxious and like I'm
showing off how much money I can spend
on headphones since they're so large and
flash Lee Nick back up since they're so
large and flashy how do I wear these
headphones without looking like a jerk
okay we got some if you could bring
those up please thank you we have some
of these are you Fiona oh god okay
[Applause]
there you go
I mean I was picturing like three times
this sizes yeah those are those are
quite subtle for New York that's
incredibly subtle yeah I was just in New
York last weekend there is no normal in
New York there is no subtle in New York
yeah I totally agree I mean I think well
first off the major thing that I would
do is I would get a t-shirt designed by
Karen and any time I wear the Beats
headphones I would wear the t-shirt and
the t-shirt would would just explain the
situation just say like I got these
headphones free with my computer I
didn't buy them I'm not the kind of
person who would buy these headphones
Shannon I'm sorry Shannon got them for
free everyone maybe we should make that
t-shirt since everyone who has Beats
headphones apparently is the same story
well give you basically a picture of
someone wearing them and say ask me
about my headphones okay I'd like to
tell you the entire story let me explain
that's I think that's it that's the
solution I'll get on it ask you fell -
yeah other than that I think um I think
like you said you don't really look like
a jerk in New York especially when
you're showing off your conspicuous
consumption Karen would you like to read
the next the next question this one
right here yeah all right dear Hank and
John it seems to me that eccentric
people are the best kind of people yes
I really admire those who have found a
quirky passion and embrace it without
irony or self-consciousness I would love
to be more eccentric but the problem is
I am drawn to fairly normal things like
crossword puzzles and books my question
is this is it possible to become more
eccentric on purpose or is true I can't
say this an eccentricity I think that's
right what was that Nik bring it back
Nik Nik back up there I'm gonna screw it
up again or is it true is or is true
eccentricity so innate the act of trying
to be eccentric just makes you a poser
wishing I had a freak flag to fly carry
it's a deep question
that's deep I don't know what do you
think I mean I don't think that
crossword puzzles and books are I mean
kind of like a freak flag yeah I watched
that documentary about competitive
crossword puzzles there's there's a
document oh it's fantastic and you do
not emerge in that documentary thinking
like well those people are putting on
their eccentric airs yeah I mean I feel
like you can be nerdy about almost
anything yeah it's just it for me
nerdiness is not so much what you're
into but the way you're into it the
level of your passion for it I think
right and that ability to not be
embarrassed about like not try to couch
it in irony proud of you're a freak like
yeah I think you do have a freak flag to
fly Kari get really into crossword
I believe in you I think she can do it
but I do think there is nothing worse
than being eccentric on purpose yeah
there's nothing subtle about that you
can pick those people out of a crowd oh
yeah yeah totally all right we got
another question this one comes from
Xena
this is a question near and dear to my
heart since my brother's not here Dear
John and Hank my sister has just moved
out to go to university in Berlin
obviously she couldn't take all of her
stuff with her as the room she is going
to live in is very small my question is
is all of what she has left behind now
mine she clearly has no use for it
anymore
so I'm thinking why should I not be
allowed to inherit the things cuz she's
not dead Xena she went to college it has
spoken like a true older brother
isn't possession nine-tenths of the law
no no I know
in podcast I'm supposed to yes and you
but no here's my story about when I went
to college beginning in the year 1983 I
started collecting baseball cards and I
was a very passionate baseball card
collector I was a huge fan of the
Chicago Cubs
I watched between a hundred and one
hundred and thirty Chicago Cubs games on
TV every year when I was like five and
six years old I had all the baseball
cards
I had a Carl Yastrzemski rookie card I
had so many great baseball cards
I had an Andre Dawson rookie card mint
condition I had what I would do is every
year whatever team won the World Series
I would I would put all of their
starting lineup for the winning game on
a page of my baseball card collection
and so you could flip through and you
could see who you know was in the
starting lineup for every World Series
winner and then after those would come
all the Cubs because they never won and
this year I don't know I've learned I've
learned not not to hope so this is what
happened I came home one summer from
college and I went to go look at my five
or six thousand baseball cards and they
weren't there and I was like what uh
what happened on my baseball cards Hank
and he said and I swear to god I'm
quoting him directly I sold them on eBay
okay I didn't see that coming seriously
yeah Hank and then I was like well then
where's my money and he was like it's my
money I inherit is your baseball card
collection when you went to college
[Laughter]
all right I mean you have two kids tell
me tell me what tell me what you have
what your approach would be in this
situation as a mother Oh
I mean on the one hand it's pretty
pretty smart at the younger one no I
mean I got to admire his you know go get
it you know but as an older as the
oldest of three kids I would kill Mike
my brother and sisters so I don't know
how Hank is still living I'm still mad
about it it's such a hate thing to do to
to be like well these baseball cards
aren't the money that they could be why
don't I turn them into money I love that
you're still mad about it too because my
sister still brings things up I mean 30
years ago I can't believe you did this
to me it was like I was 10
yeah yeah I mean but he wasn't 10 well I
think has a childlike air about him
so it's true it's a great that's a
terrible sorry oh man yeah Xena that is
not your stuff Karen thinks it might be
your stuff it's debatable
all right this question comes from
Camilla possibly Camilla I'm not very
good at pronouncing oh you want to ask
this one dear Hank and John some close
relatives of mine recently got a puppy
the problem is that they gave this puppy
a name that is also a nickname my family
uses for me it is a very obvious short
version of my full name and I was very
annoyed and hurt by this cam oh yeah cam
cam Cammy Cammy camp definitely can be I
don't why don't I go to camo first I
don't know whether my relatives simply
haven't noticed the obvious similarities
between the two names or if they just
don't care either way I find it
difficult to accept that a nickname that
I'm very fond of and have had my entire
life
now before ever associated with the dog
I might have to stop using the nickname
altogether because asking them to change
it is out of the question and I feel
like this is unfair some dubious dubious
advice on how to deal with the situation
would be greatly appreciated best wishes
probably Cammy Cammy so we were talking
about this as my son's name is James and
when he was a baby we started calling
him the peach because he had peach fuzz
and James and the Giant Peach and it's
stuck so maybe it's not kami maybe it's
something that yeah it's peach yeah that
a little known sequel that roald dahl
wrote kami a good one but would you name
your dog peach oh that would be a really
cute name for kitten I mean it would
it's that great a little like orange
fluffy it's a great name but no yeah you
can't you can't just hand can't do it I
mean my parents had a dog named Maggie
which is also a human name but we don't
know anyone named Maggie obviously
because that's horrible I think like
that's Barry I don't have any dubious
advice except that to say that you are
definitely in the right in my opinion
yeah I sympathize and this person who
did this to you that's that's just not
cool I will say when you say in the
email I mean let me find the line on
that this name you've had for your
entire life will forever be associated
with a dog you might be slightly
exaggerating the extent to which this
dog is gonna impact your life like if
you don't live with this dog if you
think about a dog you don't like close
your eyes and think about the dog that's
closest to you that you don't live with
it's probably not a super important dog
you know for me anywhere
I literally cannot think of a dog I
don't live with yeah I'm thinking I
can't that was my brother's dog nope
yeah I just died well it's a comedy
podcast about death it is very sad it is
too soon
so it's always gonna be too soon I drew
a picture of lemon Oh in the wizard
school it was very sad oh god that's so
sad and sweet and it will be available
soon oh hi that's just it's the kind of
drawing that you don't want to live
without and for $30 you won't have to
nice segue very subtle
oh man so we've we've made it like a
year Karen for a little bit of context
without having any proper sponsors but
we're starting to get sponsors reaching
out to us and just y'all probably don't
know this but my brother will not let me
sell out it's so annoying I've been
trying to sell out since 2007 Carl's jr.
offered his $5,000 to eat at Carl's jr.
hamburger navoi brothers video and I was
like yes and Hank it's like those are
disgusting and I was like I don't care
probably shouldn't have told that story
Nick Nick you might want to roll that
back it's up to you though and he won't
let me do it but I'm trying to insert as
many dftba product placements as I can
into the show all right since he's not
here okay Karen I don't know I have
another question for you this one comes
from named pending who asks Dear John
and Hank if I wanted to start writing
under a pseudonym how does that work do
I need to create a whole back story for
the life of that person including a
fictitious family yes
I think of author BIOS on a book do I
just make it all up also also if you
just pretend this is a real person or do
you have to tell strangers that it's a
pseudonym what if you pick a different
gender but then become super famous and
people want to interview you won't they
feel deceived or can you still never
tell them and just decline all in-person
interviews yes so you know pseudonym
inist people I do that was one of the I
belonged to an artist group and a lot of
us have debated this back and forth
about whether or not to have a student
him as an artist naina or your own name
and they're both they both come with
pros and cons definitely social media in
the loss of privacy is a making a whole
thing whole person up I mean are you
really John Green yeah yeah now I'm
questioning everything no if I could go
back I might not be though like yeah I
mean I think they're the nice thing well
artists pseudonyms are often like
obviously pseudonyms you know and
there's no like backstory to their lives
like you know they're they're usually
not names yeah my friend crystals is bam
Buddha which you should google BAM
Buddha cuz she's really talented right
so like but nobody thinks like BAM
Buddha is the person's real name so I
think I think that kind of pseudonym is
is good and then other than I don't the
one thing I'll say is I don't like it
maybe a personal thing but I don't like
it when male writers especially take on
female pseudonyms because I feel like
it's a way of trying to skirt around the
questions that they need to be
addressing directly I don't know if
that's right but it's always made me a
little bit uncomfortable whereas like
when Nora Roberts says that JD Robb I
don't know if you guys like Noah Roberts
but I'm a huge fan she's a romance
writer but she also writes legal
thrillers under this name JD Robb that's
not weird to me because you know because
that's the way that institutional sexism
works well when I was I mean when I
first started
when I first started subbing work to
sites and things I took a page out of JK
Rowling's book and subbed everything as
kalian and a lot thought that I was guys
sure everything on now is karen Hellion
but Kevin Kenneth Kenneth alien yeah
yeah well and now I know when I when
Kenneth Allen blows up online I'm gonna
know exactly who that is but yeah I
think I mean that's something that a lot
of women writers do especially when
they're first getting published because
there is I mean there it's not really
this it's talked about as if it's a
politicized thing and of course it is it
is political but like sexism exists and
in publishing and in most other fields
intact and an art yeah and it does
affect affects people's lives that's the
way that it works it's not like a it's
not like a vague problem or just a
political problem it's it's also a
personal problem in in everybody's real
life no I was told by a few artists who
were unhappy I kept getting printed at a
certain site that it was because I was
girl and they were choosing on Twitter
so many advanced different words then
girl but I'm sorry it's there but it is
it's there
so anyway name pending do definitely
invent an extremely complicated
backstory or if you're gonna do it do it
right yeah not like a human back story
either but like a radioactive spider
level thing where like something
happened to you and you were one person
and then he became somebody else and
maybe it's even a thing where like David
Levithan book every day where you would
have it a different body each day so
every day you have a new pseudonym I
don't know but it's got to be extreme
well then you do that and then you write
that story and then it's your
autobiography yes
it's brilliant so meta I don't even know
it
alright we had to get to this question
guys this is a difficult one I don't
want to sugarcoat it make it seem like
it's not gonna be hard to talk about
this is from Alyssa then she writes dear
John and Hank in college I volunteered
to be a model for an ad campaign for the
University and I was told to wear the
clown costume I wore for a theater
production I was in since everyone in
the shoot would be wearing crazy
costumes now I want to pause here Karen
and quickly discuss in that situation
would you have agreed to go to the shoot
wear a clown costume concert scary very
scary
no deeply scary no I'm terrified of
clowns yeah no no I would never have I
can not imagine a set of circumstances
that would result in me being in a clown
costume a dare that you lost to Hank
honey no I think I would just like I
think I would just be like by lose got
to give Hank any ideas Ella God that
would be the worst sorry I just don't
like I need to represent Hank yeah so
you're doing a great job
alright unfortunately it gets worse on
the day of the shoot I realized that I
was the only one wearing a costume
that's the word they even gave me a
laptop to hold so I could look more
casual I clown with a laptop is just so
creepy the ad became a group shot of
normal students and then me as a clown
it gets so much worse a life-sized
version of this ad has been up in the
San Antonio Airport for over three years
[Applause]
brothers how do I convince the good
people of San Antonio that I am NOT a
crazy clown lady Alyssa I think possibly
writing in and telling us this so that
now everybody knows was not the right
way to go about it oh yeah yeah I mean
I'll tell you what every listener - dear
Hank and John is booking a flight to San
Antone here right now taking a selfie
with that we have a picture here we're
gonna have Morris and I would like to
tell you that it is not terrible but I
can't lie don't lie it's a very bad
situation that I miss Asian guys this is
very dark
[Music]
to be fair clown makeup covers I mean
unfortunately Karen she's not a hidden
clown makeup she's just wearing the
clown costume it's a black and white so
oh it's awkward yeah I mean the obvious
solutions names change names plastic
surgery some kind of face altering
plastic surgery but then I think the
obvious thing embrace it
well sorry I was gonna say orange just
embrace it create a Facebook fan page
for this clown what I'm referring to
this as the Ken Bone strategy
[Laughter]
everybody's like well you're a nerd and
he's like yo
I think I think embracing it huh that's
a strong trader yeah Twitter feed
Instagram everybody posts their selfies
with it on Instagram tags are right dude
yeah just own it and then what were you
saying Hank wants you to get sponsors
right yeah we can have this college
Trinity University in San Antonio it's
where my actually one of my cousin's
went there
boy that is a bad picture we'll post it
on the patreon well she sent in the
picture I mean it's just a very bad
situation and when she says life-sized
she means nice size it's in the airport
yeah well I mean also how is that a good
advertisement for your university like
oh this you'll love going to college
here there's seven students and a clown
[Applause]
that's not good one other option that
occurred to me just now is what if
Alyssa just leaves her whole life behind
gets a pseudonym moves to Finland starts
over just like straight from scratch
writes a book writes a book under the
new suit yeah has a whole new life the
impending is not a terrible student
no I liked actually pretty good oh god
I'm so upset yeah it's good thing you're
gonna post that on patreon yeah where
you can subscribe the dear Hank and John
for as little as a dollar a month okay
we have an actually serious question
this one comes from Jasmin who writes
Dear John and Hank I like many people
and very interested in and saddened by
the global wealth disparity in poverty
in the developing world what I hear most
is that poverty or perhaps extreme
poverty is living on less than one
dollar a day American currency is often
very strong globally which makes me
wonder if this one dollar a day is a
fair
in countries where their currency is
very weak in comparison to the US dollar
for example my sister went to China
recently unreported spending less than
ten cents on a bottle of water or
something that would cost seven to ten
dollars here at home where do you live
New York yeah seven dollars for a bottle
of water yeah that's close to yeah
first if I'm getting a seven dollar
bottle of water I wish to be able to
swim in it Boston too is pretty really I
mean an indianapolis bottle of water is
about ten cents we've got ha ha ha
we've got Shanghai prices I feel like
when talking about poverty there is no
reference point other than the another
country's currency so this is really
interesting an important thing to
understand when we talk about absolute
poverty it's a doll it's usually defined
as a dollar 25 per day but it is
measured as purchasing power which a
measurement called purchasing power
which means that it is the equivalent to
a dollar 25 per day in the United States
so that is that is the amount of
purchasing power that someone living in
absolute poverty has the equivalent of
what you or I could buy here in the
United States for a dollar 25 per day
and that's why absolute poverty is so
extreme now there is absolute poverty in
the United States they're here it's
often defined as less than $2 per day
and there are more than a million people
in the u.s. living on less than $2 a day
but it's important to understand that
because it's it's it's often portrayed
as a way to get out of the poverty trap
oh you know a dollar 25 a day goes a
long way in Somalia well no it doesn't
because if because that's not the way
that it's measured so I just wanted to
be clear about that because I hear about
that all the time and I think it's
really important to understand and also
it's a great question so yeah absolute
poverty is really really really poor and
yeah no jokes there I do have a joke
about this though
wait I wanted to read one other question
what does anyone know what time it is
oh my god Oh Karen we've all we haven't
there's all these things we're supposed
to do how much time do we have
I'm so bad at hosting a pasta all right
so we do this thing where we say the
podcast is sponsored by and then I'll
start and then you'll do one it's gonna
be easy God what all right Karen this is
the part of the podcast where we thank
our sponsors okay
it's a great point I mean great point we
don't we don't okay I'd like to thank
our actual sponsor but they don't exist
so instead think about your fictional
sponsors so for instance I'm going to
start by saying that I would like to
thank don't if I find it first okay all
right yeah today's today's podcast is
brought to you by these amazing beats
headphones these brilliant beats
headphones $300 or free I was yeah I was
gonna go with Trinity oh that's great
that's great that's great is that good
yeah okay awesome
what was it Bob's Burgers no what is
hand corner Bob's Burgers Oh Carl's jr.
jr.
[Applause]
we don't have that in New England yeah
it's it's in half the country it's
Hardee's and in half the country it's
Carl's jr. it's the same disgusting
burger regardless alright so today's
podcast is brought to you by the clowns
of Trinity University take that as you
will
oh man yeah we're so grateful to Trinity
University for their continuing
sponsorship of our podcast I mean
they're spending money on that Sanford
San Antonio Airport ad how is that still
there
how can you imagine flying into that and
seeing I mean I would turn right back
around yeah I mean I guess one of the
one of the problems with this is that
you want to minimize somebody's feelings
of public embarrassment in this
situation but you can't really because
if you're walking in the airport and you
glanced over you don't ever think about
the ads in the airport no but you're
gonna think about that one you know like
you're gonna look over there and you're
gonna say oh no anyway we're here I
think I think actually there's a little
bit of dubious advice no you I was just
gonna say I feel like we're validating
her suffering oh yeah hopefully yeah we
want it like ELISA obviously this is not
her fault
no except well she did put the costume
on maybe just to be safe you should
never put on a clown costume
I really hope you lose a bank bet to
think no no I mean that's all
Hank that's no it's not on there it's
not on the docket guys I'm never getting
in a clown costume really I mean I am an
artist
[Applause]
I have drawn you before in fact I'll
have no control over whether I get into
clown costume you draw me as a cent or
yeah you had the cutie mark remember I
think I said I don't know if you've seen
it yet or not it's a character in wizard
school yeah let's hang clear this with
you no okay good
good job Hank Oh cute you know that my
little pony have those those cutie mark
sure of course yeah it was the little I
got one of those on my on my mind
yep that's great
you know what on second thought maybe
don't by wizard school yeah I'll push
that alright we've I want to get to one
more question before we get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon but no is it racing what is it
[Applause]
you know what's great you know what's
great about this like you guys are like
oh no John's feelings are hurt but in
fact you're at you're happy to educate
me aren't you yes anytime anybody's like
Wimbledon what's that I'll be like do
you have 20 minutes I would like to talk
to you about the greatest sports story
you've ever heard no I'm from Boston
oh come on the Sox attorney when they
won the World Series a great story ever
told are you kidding me
it's a great right now okay it's a great
story the Red Sox are a great story it
hurt my feelings that their curse was
broken becomes wasn't but I was very
happy for them one of my cousin's is a
huge Red Sox fan but the AFC Wimbledon
story it's just in a different league
okay
top if you got 45 minutes after the
podcast I'll tell you all about it all
right or just watch the movie in a
couple years hopefully well um yeah
rosianna and I are making it oh yeah
yeah we talked to real movie studio into
letting us make the AFC Wimbledon movie
[Applause]
all right this is our last question
before we get some questions from our
listeners here today and the news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon it comes from
Freya who writes dear Hank and John nope
Dear John and Hank I'm dating this guy
and he's recently told me that he wants
to be one of the people who goes on Elon
Musk's Mars mission how do I convince
him that this is a terrible idea
I really like him and I would like to
carry on dating but Mars is probably too
far away for a long-distance
relationship and I'm not going to Mars
with him because it is a cold dead Rock
and I have no idea why anyone would want
to go there
Freyja you are a person after my own
heart
haha Karen how do you convince your
boyfriend not to go to Mars well I mean
I was dating long-distance from
California to Boston and I convinced him
to move to Boston recently so I think
that he's just gonna stay so how do you
convince him not to go to Mars
I mean Mars is kind of cool no I mean
all right let me back up and ask you
another question do you have any advice
for that sort of cross continent
long-distance oh god it's really hard um
we Skyped every night for like Edel up
for me 11 o'clock in him 8 for the whole
like an hour at night like that was how
we kind of made it work and lots of
traveling but it was rough yeah it's
really rough it was worth it but it was
really really rough um I'm I guess the
best thing we had was communication like
constant communication and you have to
trust them completely but yeah Mars I
don't know what
the time difference would be for that
that's a great question I mean would
they be years ahead of you or behind are
you I mean are you traveling in the
future I mean what is if only we had a
science person
do they have Skype well according to the
Martian kinda but as I recall mmm
Mars is like several light minutes is it
oh yeah some one of you probably know
science Mars is several light minutes
away right like between but doesn't it
depend it depends on how it depends on
where we are that's why we can only go
to Mars in odd-numbered years which by
the way if you can only make a space
adventure in odd-numbered years that's
not a risk we're taking so the best
scenario you have to wait two years to
get picked up and in the worst scenario
you know your corpse on Mars and then
like people the distant future will be
like how did this one corpse get to Mars
I don't like they'll imagine a
civilization that never existed when it
was really is just you use
anthropologists Oh confused yes yeah I
think I think first off I don't think
there's gonna be a huge problem for
Freya because I suspect that by the time
this Mars mission actually goes in 2028
or later the the relationship will have
gone one way or the other you know any
sure and if it's a if it's a marriage or
it's a real long-term committed thing
hard to imagine well I mean if they just
started dating he's already thinking
about moving light years away that
possibly quite minutes make minutes
sorry
possibly the relationship isn't going
anywhere but oh I'm sorry though I feel
bad no I feel bad but I mean that's not
a bad point though I feel like if Sarah
came to me and she said I want to go to
Mars that would be a big red flag yeah
I'm thinking that's you know code for
something right yeah no I would
really be super alarm I mean I'm
thinking that the dating scene on Mars
is not something to be worried about
though I mean maybe on the other hand
you know when you're in a real intense
situation with just four or five people
yeah that's well yeah sure you know you
uh you ever see the movie speed god I
love that movie I love that movie so
much I know I know I've watched that so
many times
the only movie that's better is speed -
oh god that's so bad
it's so good I love I do too
I disaster movies oh I've watched what
is it God the one with the snowstorm hit
oh god it's the great movie movie have
you seen San Andreas San Andreas pick
the raw oh so good it's so good is there
a more reliable performance on earth
right now than the one consistently put
in by Dwayne the rock Johnson I love him
so much I love him I can't wait for
Moana the rock never makes a bad movie I
used sarin I used to talk about this
thing Scorpion King I didn't see that Oh
was it bad as someone who loved the
mummy uh-huh oh but I bet the rock was
good and oh well the rock was great yeah
I mean you know like when Sarah and I
first started dating we talked about
this thing called the standard Tom
Cruise six point eight which was that
pretty much every Tom Cruise movie was a
reliable six point eight like you'd go
to the movie theater and you'd be like
listen I had a good time I don't regret
it it was probably worth eight bucks was
it a good movie No do I remember the
plot not really but it was incredibly
enjoyable and the rocks like that except
instead of turning in 6.8 he
consistently turns in like 8.9 yeah I
was just gonna say 8.8 that's
that's not gonna translate to the
podcast yes what's your question um how
do you deal with nerd competition cuz
there's this kid in my English class who
okay we took this vocab test and I got
19 out of 19 I was really excited about
it and then it gets a class like Neil
what you got in the vocab test 20 out of
19 I'm like I try my best but how do you
get better than Neil in English well I
mean I was a terrible student so I'm
probably not the most qualified person
to answer this question but I think you
you have to think of the long game it's
not how did you do vs. Neil vocab test
this week it's who's gonna have the
better happier more fulfilling life in
20 years
then then you can like send a Facebook
message to me and be like what's up Neil
[Laughter]
that's my
I don't know how to compete with that I
mean you don't even know what to say
after that I mean there's definitely
some artists that I follow and I see
what they what jobs they're getting and
um makes me crazy cuz I wanted those
jobs but I think I keep trying to remind
myself that I'm competing against myself
I look at what I did a year ago or two
years ago a three years ago and see that
I'm going further and then I draw really
bad cartoons for myself of those artists
with Matt in cloud super sure to make
myself feel better
that's predictably much better advice so
first off could you send my headphones
but realistically am I so I'm a freshman
at the university Minnesota and so I'm
planning to get a degree and write a
history in history with a focus on the
Middle East and I owe people always ask
me why you're a middle class white girl
from Minnesota what are you doing why
are you learning Arabic so how do I
explain myself to or like justify I mean
I know why I'm doing it but like what do
you think is a good explanation to
placate you don't eat one you're doing
what you want to do you don't need to
explain yourself to anybody
yeah
ask them why they're not right yeah why
aren't you wearing Arabic it should be
yeah I will give you your headphones
back oh thanks
oh oh you want me to sign them I'll sign
them
I'm Sharpie in my bag I mean could not
have gone any better
yes nicely done
sorry um so as a writer and an artist um
what we're advice feet to someone who
like is more of a science math focus and
then struggles with like writing papers
are doing artistic things in school I
don't know I can't write to save my life
it's horrible to answer an email it
takes me like an hour and a half so um
my sister's my business manager she's a
writer and I think I have learned what
my strengths and my weaknesses are and
as I draw more and more every day
because they used to be a teacher for an
art teacher for a long time and I used
to love math when I was in school but
I'm finding as I become more and more
right brained other skills are falling
to the wayside my spelling has become
horrendous and like I said it takes me a
long time to put words together into to
write something legible so I think that
I have found people to help me in the
weaknesses that I have and I'll send you
know if I have to answer something and
Amy Amy will send me some interview
questions I'll do like
stream-of-consciousness and then she'll
clean it up for me and make me look good
but yeah I think I've pretty much
embraced my strengths and recognized
what my weaknesses are and then get help
where I need it Karen should have an
actual advice podcast
very good hello your face is on that
shirt I know yeah a little weird I mean
that must be very I mean I see my art on
shirts but thank God not my face yeah
cool though yeah it's very cool so Hank
has talked about how he likes to ask
people what their favorite bridges are
so the question that I am very curious
about is what your favorite inanimate
object is and if it helps mine is a coat
hanger because they are the actual worst
my favorite inanimate object least
favorite at least like is there an
object that you just abhor well yeah
this is not a very funny answer but I
have I have OCD and I cannot abide The
Velvet microfiber textures on couches or
this tablecloth is okay I checked fine
it's just so horrible and I don't
understand like why it's a commercially
available product surely no one can
handle being touched by that stuff it's
like being touched by a million fibers
per inch
you're so conscious of the fact that it
has a texture and it's so [ __ ] it's so
horrible so that sorry no I'm fine I do
it I hate it like Sarah at this point
like Sarah has to be like is this an
accessible texture for this item of
furniture and I'll be like no
[Laughter]
chok oh I can't I mean I was a teacher
and I if if there was a whiteboard I
would use it and if there's a chalkboard
I wouldn't touch it and then when I was
in art school and we had to use charcoal
which is not much better or chalk like
my fingernails are starting to just do I
can't I can't even yeah it's not
terrible terrible terrible terrible
thing sometimes when I was in school as
a kid I didn't really know why I did
this but I would hum very very quietly
and I'd try to find a way to cover my
ears when the chalking was happening of
the so just be like yeah so my sister
couldn't she would like to know if you
have any advice for introverts who are
starting college starting college oh
that's rough terrible are you an
introvert yeah yeah me too
this is kind of I mean just try to find
time for yourself try to find quiet time
that you need and and try not to feel
too much social pressure to socialize
when you don't feel like socializing
it's hard but I had a hard time in
college I was very bad at it so it's
difficult need to give advice about
something that I was so exceptionally
poor at doing but yeah I guess just like
try to take care of yourself in general
like in those stressful situations where
like something's radically new I think
you just have to try to practice really
good self-care yeah don't be don't be
ashamed of being introverted you know
don't be too hard on yourself and set
little goals like I'm gonna go to this
party for half an hour and then I'm
gonna reward myself with chocolate after
I do it kind of thing yeah that's good
yeah I'm gonna have a big chocolate bar
after this good for you
it's my reward would you rather have to
wear a clown costume for the rest of
your life or have to visit Mars or have
to what visit Mars go Mars
I mean one of those things would result
in my certain death right right yeah I
mean I guess I'd go to Mars yeah
good choice yeah you know as long as I
could bring my paddle I'd miss my wife
but she would leave me if I'd to wear a
clown costume every day so she didn't
say you couldn't bring her yeah but
realistically III know that when I go
and I say Sarah listen um I bet you Hank
had to make a weird choice no real no
real idea why this is necessary but I
either have to work the rest of my life
or I have to go to Mars your clowns on
Mars we don't know what's more you get
to Mars and you're like oh finally some
alone time
I've just been craving this and then you
get out of your spaceship clowns
everywhere yeah what are you gonna do
simile
my skirt and the damned if you don't had
a guy on Mars we're in a clown suit
all right we have time for a few more
questions okay I was gonna ask you if
you had any other great terrible
disaster movie options if this assuming
bad disaster movie date night oh yeah I
mean it would have to be like bad
disaster movie weekend I mean - volcano
ones which one do you like better
volcano or what is the other one
yes I mean this is everything okay
there's a great movie
I've got volcano I think Tommy Lee Jones
yeah he's great with that goes into the
Tom Cruise movie or the War of the
Worlds excellent love that one standard
Tom Cruise six point eight there's that
great there are those two great movies
of media or impact movies Armageddon
drape impact and deep impact was
depressing Armageddon is just popcorn
movie deep impact was pretty depressing
yeah I don't like it when they get - we
got a little deep yeah don't tell me
what it's actually gonna be like yeah
yeah in the title 12 2012 is a terrible
movie but it is a disaster yeah it's
delicious
what the core oh when they drill down
because they have to restart the core of
the earth you can see oh oh it's it's
Hillary Swank
and Hilary Swank oh you gotta it's so
good
how do you miss that one how did hilary
swank go from million dollar baby to the
core good they have to jumpstart the
core of the earth
sure of course they do otherwise how's
it going to keep spinning so good oh
well yeah sharknado sharknado is fun to
watch
live and watch the Twitter feed yeah
sharknado is only good on Twitter and
and then like so many things that when
they went back to the well it got worse
and worse and worse I will give a
shout-out for what I believe to be the
best action movie of all time which is
die hard for okay which one was that
when he had a kid no it's got Justin
Long the guy who plays the Mac in the
Mac commercial oh yeah he's got a kid
yeah okay yeah yeah I like the one
before it was Samuel Jax that is also a
great memory the weird thing about die
hard movies is that they it was the
first one which was great there was the
second one which was okay there was the
third one which is great the fourth one
which i think is the greatest movie of
all time and then the fifth one which is
the worst it's so bad it's just it's
unenjoyable or well you need to watch
the core okay all right those are our
vice beautiful thank you okay what is
your favorite Pokemon both work what
would you pick as a starter in original
Pokemon and what is your favorite of the
151 originals oh yeah 25 I'm mystic I'm
team Team Red
what is your favorite what is your what
would you pick as your starter oh god
well my son picked my starter for me and
I think he picked Pikachu but I could it
was he starter yeah I'm just I'm new to
Pokemon in the last like six months you
can hack it to make you could choose
possible we started with
Oertel my favorite Pokemon to have I was
in England for six days I spent I don't
want to tell you how much money on data
to catch a stupid mr. mime she can only
catch in Europe it's the only one you
can catch only in Europe and on my sixth
day I took a five mile long walk along
the river and at no point did I look up
to see the sights
it's just tracking mr. mime and then he
showed up right outside the Tate Modern
and it took 20 ultra balls and twenty
one and twenty raspberries he didn't run
it was it was an epic battle he was
staring me down the most horrifying ugly
Pokemon is essentially the clown Pokemon
and I was sweating it was the most
intense fight I've had since middle
school and when I caught him when it
said gotcha I thought I was gonna start
crying
[Laughter]
and then I sent Sara a bunch of
screenshots and she was like I don't
care
[Laughter]
I don't have an epic story like that I
have a little sentimental one my son
Ryan's favorite animals a tiger so he
likes the growlithe yes so I have two of
them and one of them I named our quraían
and the other one is named for my
youngest son who wants to be just like
his older brother so he likes Tigers too
James listen
so those amazing I know there's very
cute that's very cute story alright I
apologized everybody's questions we're
not gonna get to it but this is gonna
have to be the last one I think sorry so
my friends and I have had a question
that we've been debating for 10 years
this was pre ham or Hamilton so don't
let that impact your answer too much but
we wondered what your you consider to be
the foxiest founding father all right so
what are the with what are what is
considered the founding fathers we have
gotten Abraham Lincoln as an answer so
he's not a found no he's good guy
foxy some girls like that yeah he was
tall it's tall um you did also say if I
had two faces would I be wearing this
one I guess for me you got that it's a
tough one I can't get Hamilton out of my
head yeah I mean presentin is so much
[Laughter]
all I can see is to be Diggs dancing as
Jefferson Jefferson is also very hot
yeah yeah stuff this is tough this is
real tough ah and then I'm trying to
like I'm trying to reach and come up
with some more obscure founding fathers
but like looking at them I'm not
thrilled with any of them in my mind
Franklin's like 87 years old I'm gonna
go with Hamilton I think I would have
picked Hamilton pre Hamilton I mean I
don't want to copy him but I'm gonna go
with Hamilton
yeah I mean the musical Hamilton it
would be all daveed Diggs but I'm
thinking the real ones Hamilton sorry
yeah one more question
hi
I'm really nervous now I'm asexual and
aromantic and it can kind of be awkward
if I'm hanging out with like my friends
who have significant others I feel like
I'm third-wheeling like all the time do
you have do you have any arrow ace
friends and you have any advice for
couples to kind of interact with people
who choose to be single yeah we do have
an ace friend who we hang out with
sometimes we don't well you know we
don't socialize much because we have
young children it's I'm just gonna say I
don't really ever go out anymore so I
yeah of all my friends whenever I talk
about any of my friends and like we hang
out sometimes you know like four times a
year conventions when I go to
conventions that's the only time I have
a social life yeah that's it at home I
don't um and I guess I mean the main
thing I guess in in this I have very
limited experience in this but the only
thing I'd say is that it's not as a
person who's in a couple it's not
uncomfortable for me to be in this
situation
like I don't feel like like your
third-wheeling if that makes sense like
if when we're hanging out with a single
friend I don't ever feel like they're
incomplete you know or that they're not
they're not like pulling their weight or
whatever is in many cases when people
you know have a partner you don't like
the partner nearly as much as you like
your friend yep so it's sort of worse
and sometimes at least you know and then
you have to just be like oh god that
guy's gonna be there I wish there was a
way to hang out with that guy without
hanging out with that other guy okay
hope the friend I'm thinking about
doesn't apparently have 15 minutes left
shoot did you is that more than you
thought or less that's the more than I
thought oh that's good that would get to
a couple more questions so yeah I guess
that's what I would say like is that and
maybe and maybe also just acknowledge it
sometimes sometimes things are
uncomfortable because we don't talk
about them and then when you acknowledge
them they become easier but yeah I don't
know it's pretty dubious advice thank
you
hi my name is Ryan
oh no way is it really so I'll tell you
all when this person Ryan wrote in they
said their name Ryan like six different
times in the email but then I also added
it six more times and so what's going on
yesterday you talked about the trolley
problem when you were talking about the
end of The Fault in Our Stars um so what
are your thoughts on the trolley problem
what would your solution be do you know
what this is wrong my problem the
trolley problem yeah oh god I thought
you said front problem and I was like
let's not do that oh thank god we have
another no don't let's not trolley
problem sorry you may be thinking about
our problem I always like I always get
it wrong so I'm just gonna tell you guys
the wrong trolley problem cuz I always
get it wrong basically there's three
people tied to the tracks and then
there's
yep right let's say there's three people
tied to the tracks thank you and there's
a trolley coming it's definitely gonna
run them over you can pull a switch that
will send the trolley to a different
path but then it will run over two
people and you can see those two people
and also you have to pull the switch to
have it go and then so you what do you
do most people make the passive choice
believing that it's not a choice that
they don't become a participant in this
hypothetical murder I mean the good
thing about the trolley problem right is
that most of us probably are never gonna
find ourselves in a situation where we
can do that but then on some level like
we're always constantly making decisions
passive decisions that you know are
probably not unlike the broad interest
of the human species but are in the
interest of like the people close to us
which is what the trolley problem is or
one of the things that it's about I
guess I do not have a solution for it
that's my solution he would get them all
right and then stop the truck God he
would he would get them all and he would
just be like yeah you know the rock eats
six pounds of cod every day I follow him
on Instagram yeah I know it's just an
amazing person yes do you know that you
know so when when you do press junkets
it's a weird a horrible it's I don't
want to like complain about movie stuff
but press junkets are pretty it's bad as
movie stuff gets and basically you sit
you sit in a room in a very small hot
room and every six minutes a different
reporter comes in and interviews you and
it's totally dehumanizing for everyone
involved and you cannot think about the
reporter and they ask you the same
questions over and over again and it's
almost impossible to think of these
reporters as like people because you're
so nervous about saying something wrong
and getting in trouble or whatever and
it's just like and it goes on for hours
so you need
hundreds of these people when I did the
Paper Towns tour I think I did like 500
press junket interviews and it's and I'm
not the rock when the rock does it for
like Fast & Furious 7 it goes on for
weeks and weeks and weeks and weeks and
but the rock is amazing
everyone I've ever talked to in the
press they're all like you know who's
great the rock he's so nice he's so
caring and I saw this YouTube video you
can look it up it's pretty amazing his
guy interviews the rock everytime the
rock has a movie out and the rock
remembers him every time and they always
do something like fun and cool together
and to surprise him the rock officiated
his wedding of course he did
you know people say we live in a like
you know and you know in a post god
world but maybe not I know God have you
met him
oh no no I I couldn't bear everything I
was two steps like the Kevin Bacon wait
if you had met him then maybe I'd beat
him I think he gave me an MTV Movie
Award at MTV Movie Award funny story
about it actually
we want the Fault in Our Stars one MTV
MTV Movie Award for movie of the year
which was really cool and but I didn't
get a an award like the director did I
mean you know to be fair I also didn't
have anything to do with making the
movie so I probably didn't deserve an
award but um you know the director got
one and the actors got one and the
producers got one and I didn't get one
and then I called the producer of the
movie and I was like hey can I get one
of those MTV Awards and he was like
there are 300 bucks apiece and I was
like can I get one anyway and he did he
got me one but yeah so it's in my
basement it's pretty it's pretty great
that is the best the coolest award I
have I'll have a Nickelodeon Kids Choice
Award oh did you know I didn't get to go
to the show but it was still cool yeah
those are those are the two weird things
that happened to me I hope we answered
your question the trolley question oh
yeah we did the rock yeah the wrong Rock
The Rock from now on that's the answer
The Rock okay um I just wanted to remind
you that you actually did plug Hardee's
and an abundance of katherines and I
wanted to know if you were gonna retro
actively ask for your $5,000 or me
maybe for 478 monster thickburger x' Oh
God
[Applause]
you say you've never been to Hardee's
hmm well I don't think no really
your life won't get any better I mean I
wouldn't say that I plugged it in
abundance of katherines so much as I
acknowledged its existence but there is
a yeah there is a weird history of this
in American fiction of writers getting
paid to do product placement basically I
do not do that
Oh like in their books in fact there was
a really interesting huh sorry good
nevermind
yeah just like in the background of
wizard school aren't just a bunch of
Hardy signs man they're always coming
from Hardy's are going too hard see if
we've been working on wizard school
together that would have had yes sorry
um no I would not I would never do paid
product placement in a book they would I
mean that would be bad I'm not that bad
hello hi so I had an embarrassing
experience yesterday where I was
volunteering for the writers panel and I
met you and Ben blacker John and I got a
little star-struck and forgot to tell
you that although my name was not
Maureen Johnson that actually was me so
my question is what is your advice for
people like me who tend to freeze and
make fools of themselves when
encountering people who are
significantly cooler than them like you
and Karen the first time I met him was
at VidCon
Hank flew me out to VidCon to promote
wizard school and we had just set up and
he turns the corner and I learned was a
cop John Green
I mean this is only the second time
we've met and I'm still kind of freaking
out right now
I seem to be no I I freaked out about
other artists that I meet at comic-con
my friend I say friend now and I feel
like I'm faking that but Katie cook
who's an incredible artist the first
time I met her I think I was just
starting to pursue art and I had gone to
a con just to kind of check out what it
was like and I went up to her and I was
like oh my god I love you so much and
you're so great and everything she's
like oh I think I've seen some of your
work I have one of your shirts I was
like oh and I still I mean I've seen her
at conventions and I'm friends with her
and Facebook for the last couple years
and I still freak out when I see her and
I'm still like completely in with Hank I
mean I don't know what the vet I mean I
think but I've also been on the other
side in the last couple years I've been
lucky enough that people come up to me
and they kind of get starstruck and
nervous and seeing what it feels like on
the other side and knowing that there's
absolutely no reason to be nervous at
all I know it doesn't help logically
like because I'm still but I think I
know I get completely nervous it goes
both ways I think it's just normal I
think it's good it means you're excited
to be talking to somebody yeah I mean I
I think the main thing is like sometimes
after one of those encounters ha I will
like break it down in my head
obsessively and feel like ah God it was
such an idiot I was such an
embarrassment I can't believe that I
said that and they don't care they don't
they don't remember Jeffrey you Jenna DS
has no idea that he met me he has no
memory of meeting me he does not care
what I said it went in one ear and out
the other
that's what I tell myself anyway like
when I met Sherman Alexie I was just
like
and yeah I mean it was a disaster but
like you just got to let it go got to
let it go so I'm trying to let it go
still my strategy is to get in say thank
you and get out yeah just get out fast
like treat it like a burning car
it's also possible but I forgot to say
thank Cindy that's nice
I'm very sorry that we have to wrap it
up now but I'm getting to wrap it up son
from our friend in the back I'm sorry
that we didn't get to answer your
question nice person who's next in line
I apologize should we give them this
this tried oh this is the guy who time
to find out who talked more in the
podcast with his sister
[Applause]
can someone please Google the AFC
Wimbledon's Swindon Town score how far
in the game is it I love you guys for
caring I love it so much
gentle reminder that you could too can
become an owner of AFC Wimbledon by
joining the Dons Trust for just 25
pounds which these days it's like eight
dollars yeah that's true so so the news
from AFC Wimbledon is that they are
currently playing Swindon Town just for
a little bit of context yeah alright so
in English soccer
there's the teams at the top that's the
Premier League you know like Manchester
United you ever heard of them yes
Chelsea Liverpool okay Liverpool owned
by the Boston Red Sox owner John Henry
and then and then if you're a really bad
team in the Premier League the bottom
three teams each year get relegated down
to the league below that which is called
helpfully the championship right and
then the best teams in the championship
get promoted up to the Premier League
each season because the worst teams have
from the Premier League have been
relegated the worst teams from the
championship get relegated down to the
third tier of English soccer which and
this is a totally reasonable decision is
called League One and beneath that you
have League Two the fourth tier of
English soccer and then beneath that
it's semi-pro slash amateur so these are
the professional full-time professional
leagues AFC Wimbledon is currently
located happily comfortably right in the
middle about there this is a very visual
gag for a podcast and they're playing
Swindon Town who's about there just
below them and it's 0-0 at halftime
that's the update okay so from because I
need more context great
that's a team yeah I thought it was a
league or something it's a team and they
play soccer correct all right so if you
could sign this I'm gonna sell this on
eBay alternately we could give it to the
best question but if you want to sell it
on eBay that's the news from the news
from Mars is that Elon Musk I said that
if you want to go to Mars you should be
prepared to die there and leave your
girlfriend behind so he really did say
that
so did he really oh yeah I mean yeah but
things that you know ya really
articulated right yeah yeah
would you ever is there ever a world in
which you would go to space if I didn't
have kids yes what keep me here like I
but what if you're like 80 your kids are
grown up they've got good lives I'm
hoping they're gonna be grown up when
I'm 60 how about 60 it's a good point
yeah well I mean then there might be
grandchildren it's true and those you
get to spoil and not have to discipline
it I'm really looking forward to that
it's true it's true it's tough if I
didn't have kids I would definitely be
in in interested in doing much more
something like that but those kids keep
you on earth I would I wouldn't I
wouldn't go to space for all the money
in the world why
it just sounds terrible
I'm a little claustrophobic so now that
I think about it possibly I mean I get
nauseated just from being up on stage
well that's a whole different thing
looking at you thanks Karen
all right so what did we learn today
Karen well I learned that AFC Wimbledon
is a team and they don't play tennis so
I think I'm ahead of the game this
morning
yeah that's true I learned never put on
a clown suit never ever dangerous those
are what headphones look like the beep
ones yeah
how is picturing something much more
elaborate yeah those are not that big
yeah but I grew up in the 80s where
everything was hair was right you like
held in your huge hair with your jacket
yeah and lastly we learned hey can I do
this every week we're like what about
today lastly and lastly we learned don't
name your dog Cammy yeah Karen thank you
so much for potting with me thank you
for having me again you can find Karen's
stuff at Etsy or all over the internet
what's your website
Karen Haley and don't go no works out
really well not to have a name visit
John Green John Green Comm owned by a
realtor in Southern Mississippi and has
been since like 1992
thank you for yeah thank you for ponding
with me thanks everybody for your
questions you can email us at Hank and
John at gmail.com or you can also send
us tweets with the hashtag dear Hank and
John I'm John Green Hank is Hank green
karen is Hank green too
[Applause]
[Applause]
and of course ELISA is at clown orissa
this podcast is edited by Nicholas
Jenkins Victoria Bongiorno helps out
with social media
rosianna halse rojas helps with many
many things including questions our
theme music is by gonna roll the rola
yeah he's great
one of the one of my favorite youtubers
and as we say in my hometown don't
forget to be awesome
we should only got together great idea
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you guys are smart there we go here we
go roll it back man and as we say in our
hometown great thank you guys so much
this has been such a pleasure you can
listen to it in a few weeks when Hank is
on paternity leave and have a wonderful
day thanks Karen
[Music]